pour en parler sur ce plateau avec nous
aussi dit en scène est journaliste
indépendant et spécialiste de la guinée
monsieur hissein merci d'être avec nous
tous genres persil plat on vient de le
voir un deux manifestants tués hier au
moins 20 civils tués depuis le début de
cette mobilisation massive et à
manifestation s'est déroulée à rarement
dans l'apaisement en guinée pourquoi ça
c'est on peut dire que c'est un peu
c'est bien malheureusement quelque chose
de culturel mais a quand même une chose
qui a changé depuis l'arrivée d'alpha
condé le président actuel en 2010 c'est
que désormais a quand même des
manifestations qui se tiennent avant
c'était quasiment impossible c'est très
compliqué ça c'est toujours par des
morts las affine encore par des morts
généralement mais il ya au moins une
opposition une société civile qui s'est
exprimée depuis 9 10 ans maintenant elle
arriva sur doit sortir dans la rue et
lifetime on arrive à un point de tension
ou le président alpha condé rivas à la
fin de son mandat il a évidemment les
choses seraient 10 s'aggraver on sent
bien que la tension augmente dans le
pays
alors elle faconde et on le sait veut
réformer la constitution en tout cas
veut sommêtres veut soumettre un projet
de nouvelle constitution
on le soupçonne de faire cela pour
briguer un troisième mandat on est
encore au stade des soupçons
jusqu'à là oui mais le problème du
gouvernement et du président alpha condé
lui-même sait que ils ne font que
renforcer ces soupçons
il n'y a absolument aucun mot aucun même
pas de sensibilisation sur cette
reconstitution dont on connaît le
contenu il ya seulement enfin depuis
seulement un mois
or ça fait bientôt maintenant un an que
le gouvernement et le pouvoir ne cesse
de faire la promotion d'un texte dont on
ignorer absolument tout jusqu'en
décembre dernier
donc il faut dire que les propos
belliqueux de sienne bas que tient aussi
faut le dire le premier des guinéens le
présent faconde et qui tient les propos
de plus en plus graves où il faut créer
lui-même une fracture au sein de la
guinée est aussi là l'opposition et
l'aspect civil qui se radicalise qui
demandent désormais le départ pur et
simple que sa faconde et plutôt que de
demander simplement le retrait du texte
du projet de texte comme comme comme une
faille jusqu'à présent on sent bien que
là les choses pour enfants sont en train
de se radicaliser et les morts je le
crains qu'on continue à s'accumuler sur
le sur le pays qui n'a justement quel
est son bilan alpha condé le problème du
président alpha condé je pense c'est le
problème de ces aussi de ses
prédécesseurs c'est qu'en fait l'état
guinéen est un état qui est qui qui est
fracturée en fait qui est cassé depuis
la mort du prix présent de la guinée le
père la nation ahmed sékou touré donc
depuis 984 qui me permet à ses coutures
et pendant 26 ans à imposer son projet
de révolution permanente ce qui est bon
et qui a fait le corps et de la guinée
une espèce de mini corée du nord à
l'époque pour pour organiser un peu mais
depuis sa mort il n'a absolument aucune
valeur aucun symbole qui aurait permis
aux guinéens de se rassembler en tant
que nation et a que des flamands des
gérants qui s'assied sur le trône et qui
gère les affaires au quotidien et le la
déception je pense que ressentent la
partie des guinéens
concernant alpha condé ce qu'est ce que
l'opposant historique celui qui était
intransigeant qui n'a jamais collaboré
son plaisir ça comme ça avec les
gouvernements précédents même le moindre
petit poste de
l'administratif il nage il a toujours
refusé en fait de négocier de transiger
sur la démocratie et on s'attendait à ce
que pendant dix ans il vient au moins
avec un programme clair et et des
symboles nouveau et un projet de société
clair et c'est ce monde donc je pense
les guinéens ce symbole là parce qu'on
voit que depuis dix ans il faut quand
même admettre présent faconde et on
navigue à vue on comprend pas vraiment
quelle est sa gouvernance quoi et nous
reste un vrai problème et c'est pour ça
qu'aujourd'hui d'ailleurs sont près de
constitution à tous les toutous les
difficultés à s'imposer dans l'esprit
des guinéens parce que il n'est même pas
une notion gouvernement n'a pas été
capable aussi de sensibiliser clairement
sur le projet de ceux de cette
constitution est ce qui pourrait amener
clairement pour la nation guinéenne
est-ce que l'opposition est efficace en
guinée s qui avait régné en tout cas
alors durant le premier mandat de 2010 à
2011 2015 donc voilà on pouvait dire oui
à la fin du premier mandat de monsieur
alpha condé donc en 2015 à sa réélection
en 2015 l'opposition était fracturé et
certains ont rejoint le pouvoir il faut
dire que la transhumance politique en
guinée c'est un peu un sport national
donc mais elles étaient unis jusqu'en
2015 puis une vraie véritable fissures
mais aujourd'hui elle en train de se
remobiliser d'associer civile parce
qu'il faut comprendre une chose c'est
que le présente faconde et à ses
réélections avait un boulevard devant
lui
la maladie hezbollah était en train sur
le point d'être vaincus ou voir même
vaincu donc les milliards
d'investissements de dollars hrw lever
de nouveau sur le territoire guinéen
l'eau pays sont fracturées société
civile ellle été et que c'est lui même
et son gouvernement bien évidemment qui
n'ont pas su répondre aux attentes de la
population des foyers de contestation
ont explosé en appartement de pays même
dans son propre fief d'autres guinée sur
diverses choses l'emploi le travail
évidemment l'électricité l'énergie
l'accès à l'eau au travail que les
familles la pollution liée à l'activité
minière et le président et son
gouvernement et ses îles sont vraiment
ils n'ont pas été capables de tendre la
main pour un dialogue ouvert c'était
vraiment un plaisir du poing sur la
table et aujourd'hui cette politique là
avec en plus ce premier troisième mandat
donc une espèce devant une nouvelle
présidence à vie comme les cds
prédécesseur l'opposition s'est de
nouveau réuni fier alors pas tout mais
surtout la société civile on voit là des
gens défiler parmi lyon s'est quasiment
jamais arrivé en guinée avec une couleur
symbole un hymne aussi
une gouaille voilà des symboles des
gestes des marqueurs et puis surtout un
discours et des figures relativement
jeune qui maintenant tu portes un vrai
discours de changement comment vous
voyez l'avenir en tout cas l'issue parce
que le fn décès appelé à une
mobilisation massive et illimité or on a
eu deux manifestants tués est ce que la
mobilisation peut tout même continuer là
ça va dépendre je pense que là je pense
qu'il faut quand même le dire le dernier
mot revient au président de la
république c'est lui qui a le pouvoir en
fait de tout arrêter là l'opposition le
fn le fn et c'est donc l'aspect civile
et les partis d'opposition semble se
radicaliser il demande désormais le
départ ils manifestent tous les jours
le président alpha condé ne semble pas
vouloir
comment dire infléchir sa position
et pourtant c'est lui qui détient
l'avenir et le destin de ces pays entre
ses mains il il aimerait rentrer dans
l'histoire il peut encore le faire en ce
moment en respectant la constitution et
en étant le premier président qui
permettra en fait une transition enfin
l'alternance démocratique apaisée dans
ce pays ce qui n'est jamais arrivé
en 61 ans d'indépendance peut-être à un
dernier mot rapidement sur la marge la
marge de manoeuvre de l'union africaine
et peut-être de la cedeao
je pense qu'elle est nous offrir la
vidéo n'ont jamais france ont d'autres
problèmes sur le continent ils n'ont
jamais vraiment pesé ce genre de
problème ça serait que généralement
nationalement c'est extrêmement rare que
l'union africaine et la cedeao arrive à
imposer une espèce de direction un
président sauf après de multiples
négociations pendant des mois et des
mois et il faut aussi comprendre que non
en afrique
alpha condé c'est quand même l'un des
plus vieux c'est l'aîné et ces choses-là
compte beaucoup dans les négociations
aussi quand même si dix ans ce n'est
merci beaucoup pour ces précisions je
rappelle que vous êtes un journaliste
indépendant et spécialiste de la guinée
merci